Critical phenomena arise at transitions.
The idea is that when the system is
just at this edge of order and disorder,
interesting complex dynamics can arise.
As a physicist, critical phenomena is
extremely appealing because it appears
in many phenomena — from the evolution of the
universe to the properties of superconductors,
flocks of starlings, networks of brain cells,
tectonic plates, social interactions among humans,
all these types of things. Any time I can
see one equation apply to lots and lots of
different things, I think that’s beautiful. It’s
economical. It’s insightful. Which raises a really
profound question: Why? Why are so many things
in nature operating near the critical point?
When physical systems go through phase
transitions, such as when water transitions
from a liquid into a vapor because of a
change in temperature, the system moves
through what’s known as the critical point
– a fleeting moment of transition from one
phase to another characterized by exotic emergent
properties that have long intrigued scientists.
Critical systems have this property
of changing phase. Small changes in
some critical environmental variable lead
to drastic changes — almost discontinuous
changes — in the function. And it’s that
kind of observation that leads us to believe
that the study of critical
transitions is valuable.
Critical dynamics are best demonstrated in a
simplified system known as the Ising model,
which visualizes the individual iron atoms making
up a magnet with arrows to indicate
the direction of each atom’s spin.
You can imagine a lattice. And on this lattice you
get all these little spins that
can point either up or down.
And when this lattice is really cold,
what will happen is all the spins will
line up together. So the nearest
neighbor interactions will cause
them all to point in the same direction.
This piece of iron — BING! It would stick
on your refrigerator because all the
bar magnets are in the same direction.
But now if you heat this up — if you took
a little Bic lighter and you put it under
it — what would happen is these little
spins would start moving. They start
going in different directions. And then they
would eventually cancel. Some of them would
point up and some of them would point down, and
then it would fall off of your refrigerator.
So you get a phase transition from being
very ordered to being totally disordered.
As it passes from order to disorder, the system
moves through the critical point and clusters of
similarly oriented spins form throughout the
lattice. If you were to measure the sizes of
these clusters at various scales, the data would
reveal what’s known as a power law, where dynamics
at one scale mirror the dynamics at other scales.
This phenomenon is also known as scale invariance.
Scale invariance is another way of saying that
there is self-similarity or fractality.These
kinds of properties are spectacular because indeed
everything simplifies at the critical point.
When a system reaches the critical point,
it displays a telltale peak in what is known
as the correlation length — an indication of
how sensitive the system as a whole is to
the activity of any one of its components.
What happens is the system behaves in ways that
allow fluctuations to occur over
the scale of the entire system.
If it was too cold, you’d have no correlation
because they’re just pointing. They’re not
moving. And when it’s too hot, they’re
moving a lot, but they’re not correlated.
So only at that sweet spot right in the
middle do you have interactions at all scales.
Now, what that means is something very weird.
That means that the distance over which these
spins might interact is technically infinite.
I could take a spin over here and flip it,
and there’s some nonzero probability that
another spin very, very far away would flip
also as a result of it. So in other words, I
can initiate a cascade of events that would
propagate through the system, and it would have
some nonzero probability of affecting that.
In 1987, the physicist Per Bak wondered if
many different types of complex systems in
the natural world might self-organize
around critical points. To illustrate
his theory of “self-organized criticality,”
Bak used the familiar example of a sandpile.
As the pile gains mass, friction can no
longer hold the grains of sand in place,
and a single grain added to the pile
will trigger an outsized effect,
sending avalanches cascading down its sides.
And it turns out that if you look at the
distribution of avalanche sizes — the big ones,
the small ones, the intermediate
ones — they follow power laws.
And so Per Bak’s idea was that, hey, here’s
a natural system that self-organizes to the
critical point. You don’t need to tune it
there. You don’t need to get just the right
control temperature to put the Ising
model. It will evolve into that state.
And so when he came out with this
concept of self-organized criticality,
he was claiming that many natural
systems fall into that category,
like earthquakes, like stock
market crashes, like piles of sand.
Now, he was a pioneer, and it
was amazing that he did that,
and it inspired many people from
other areas to enter into the
field of criticality and to take a look at
this concept and apply it more generally.
And I would say basically it’s had
huge amounts of traction. However,
there have been people who
have been quite skeptical.
Bak’s equations only account for one grain of
sand hitting the pile at a time. In nature,
things are more complicated, and researchers have
found it difficult to simulate true criticality.
This is a general problem of mathematical models
just to be always aware of: At what point have you
overextended that simple abstraction and
applied it in a way that’s inadmissible?
And so SOC is just one mechanism for tuning to
critical points. It’s a very interesting one,
but perhaps it will turn out to be a rare one.
Despite the criticism, Bak’s work
inspired interest in criticality
throughout the 1990s and into the early
2000s, when neuroscientists began to probe
a new question: whether brains might
exhibit self-organized criticality.
Per Bak’s work opened up the concept that
criticality could apply to many different things,
and that made me think: We’ve got lots of
neurons that are interacting in this network,
so, hey, why not? So we just started
to apply that framework to the data.
The idea that the brain is at the
transition point — for example,
at criticality, at the transition between order
and chaos — has been around for a while. I think
the real avalanche of criticality research was
triggered by John Beggs and Dietmar Plenz in 2003.
We isolated the gray matter. The cortex has a
piece of tissue. When it was young, we grew it on
a microelectrode array in a dish. We let it grow
for about four weeks and we measured the activity,
how these cells would interact with each other.
And we found that in layers II, III, they start to
form groups like just these cascades that were
predicted by the Per Bak sandpile model. And
plotting avalanche science distributions
and sure enough, they were power laws.
It was the first paper that claimed that the brain
was probably functioning at a critical point.
The question for scientists then became:
Why? Why might functioning at a
critical point be helpful for brains?
Can you show that operating near the
critical point actually increases
behavioral performance? And when you’re
not near the critical point, it doesn’t?
So why would being at the critical
point be to your evolutionary advantage?
So let’s say you’re at the side of a river and
there’s a bunch of reeds and they’re blowing in
the wind. And then you notice that, hey, this is
different from yesterday. I think there’s a tiger.
So you want to be very sensitive to inputs. The
system is most susceptible to slight changes
in inputs when it’s near the critical point. It
has these large fluctuations that can take off.
According to the critical brain hypothesis,
when the network is right at criticality,
it’s perfectly balanced between two extreme
states: super-criticality, in which networks
of neurons display the highly ordered runaway
excitations seen in epilepsy, and sub-criticality,
in which signals fail to trigger larger cascades
and stall out, as seen in comatose states.
By hovering near the critical point,
the theory goes, networks of neurons would
be optimized for information transmission.
Just like in the Ising model, tiny inputs could
result in big, complex behaviors in the network.
Proving that such a measurement
of optimal brain activity exists
would give researchers a new scale to
interpret just about everything brains do.
When we first got our results back from
the 2003 paper, I was just enamored with
the idea of criticality. I was in love
with it. I’d go to bed thinking, “Oh,
it’s optimal information transmission. We get
the — just the right exponents. It’s all cool.”
And then over time, people started
to question this in various ways.
Just as with Per Bak’s sandpile model,
scientists began to question whether the
physics of criticality could neatly apply
to such a chaotic biological system with
so many variables interacting all at once.
In simpler systems like the Ising model, a
single variable like temperature can be adjusted
to bring the network right to the critical
point. But in complex biological systems,
the prospect of tuning to the exact point
of criticality would be much more difficult.
The brain is constantly receiving inputs from
outside that could, you know, blow it off of
the critical point. So for those reasons alone, it
can’t really be exactly critical. Then what is it?
One of the options of many on the
menu about how the brain is actually
operating is that it’s slightly
sub-critical, and that it doesn’t
really get to the critical point
because that might be dangerous.
Another plausible idea is that it’s quasicritical.
And what that means is that it gets as close to
the critical point as it can. But then there’s
this activity that’s basically going to push
it away from being right at the critical point.
As research continues to reveal
tantalizing signatures of criticality,
what was once a fringe theory has begun to
attract more mainstream attention in the field,
with researchers now hunting for what kinds of
mechanisms might be responsible for
tuning brains to the critical point.
The big question that is unanswered so far is
what is the homeostatic mechanism bringing back
the brain to this quasi-criticality region?
That’s a big question — a big open question.
That’s the million-dollar question.
Neuroscience has been and continues to be very
hesitant and reluctant to agree on a theoretical
idea of the kind that criticality offers. Most
neuroscientists are very hard-nosed empiricists.
They don’t believe that there is an overarching
theory that explains most — or, you know, god
forbid — all of what the brain is doing in
one handy concept such as critical state.
I personally think that what does not
play well with neuroscientists is if
criticality is portrayed as the answer to
everything. I think that is overselling it.
And yet I have no doubt believing
that a system like the brain almost
requires us to be in a critical state for
it to function well or optimally, even.
There might also be one equation that explains how
the whole thing works. That’s the idealized dream.
We may never, ever get there, but the hope is
that there might be some general principles
that really explain how intelligence
functions in this world that we live in.
The field wasn’t there 20 years ago when we had
just one idea, a sandpile model or an Ising model,
that would guide us. We are way beyond that. And
we are at the point now where the technological
advance in neuroscience to record the individual
spiking activity for many, many thousands of
neurons…. These are the precision tools that we
need in order to test new ideas on criticality.
How is the collective coming together to
produce outcomes that are way beyond what
an individual could do? And I think this is
how our society is organized. This is how
our brain, our body is organized. And
any understanding of the richness that
we gain when we operate as a collective, I
think, is just beautiful scientific insight.